this is Jebel Ali Basha on the sweets of
seductive for the rebel commander this
is just the beginning of a long push to
recapture lost territory under our
control we have managed to evict Syrian
army Russian Ally and pro-government
militias from Serato I want to reassure
our people that we will liberate all the
cities of Syria and defeat the dictator
but for the rebels to hold ground may be
challenging the city is located on two
highways m4 and m5 which linked Damascus
to Aleppo and northeastern Syria Syrian
government troops and Russian fighter
jets are striking rebel positions
preventing them from reinforcing their
lines of defense a rare moment of
triumph for the rebels this is their
first significant military game in
months the opposition has lost many
strongholds and retreated north allowing
the Syrian army to advance towards it
lib city and as government troops close
in thousands of civilians flee the
offensive has displaced almost 1 million
people and created the worst
humanitarian situation since the start
of the conflict in Syria nine years ago
here's the latest from what is happening
on the ground now
after securing Salah have the rebels
have managed to take over other villages
in the area and saying that the next
step would be to take over another
crucial area which is moderate enderman
it was in the past a government it was a
rebel stronghold but then it fell under
the the control of the Syrian army so
while the Syrian rebels are making those
gains government troops on the other
hands I was trying to take control of
areas in jelas area in the south of the
province of village the palace area was
from 2011 one of the most important
bastions of the Syrian opposition and it
seems that the government is adamant to
take over Jabara Zawiya because that
would pave the way for
it's troops to move forward towards the
city of Aleppo we're seeing is a
spectacular shifting political ground in
Eid Lib and rural parts of Aleppo the
Russians and the Syrian government on
one hand moving forward
the rebels backed by Turkey trying to
reverse the those gains however as the
situation intensifies as the fighting
continues the international community
continues to worry about the potential
for yet a massive humanitarian
catastrophe in Syria almost 1 million
people were evicted from their homes
most of those people are now stranded on
the border with Turkey and if the
fighting continues we're likely to see
more people leaving their areas and
moving to those makeshift camps in the
open Jara ok Hashima Jabara bring us all
the very latest there from the
turkey-syria border thank you